hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today today
let's solve reverse nodes
in a k group now this is a hard problem
but it's actually not as hard as you
might think
so we're given one linked list and we
want to reverse
the nodes of that linked list a at a
time
and then return the output so what do
they actually
mean when they say k at a time so
in the example that we're going to look
at let's say k is 2.
we basically take this input right we
see there's
five nodes we want to look at each
group of size k so each group
of size two this is one group this is
one group
and the last group doesn't even have k
elements and what we want to do to each
group
so let's look at the first group we just
want to reverse it
so now this has been reversed and we
also want it to still be a part of this
entire linked list so what we have to do
is for this
one we have to set its next pointer over
here
and in the output you can see that
this group is reversed now we do the
same thing with the
second group so four's next is actually
going to be
three now we've reversed this and then
the output
it's also reversed now they tell us if
we have a special group
right like the last group doesn't even
have k elements
so if it's not a multiple of k then it
should just remain
as it is so we really don't have to make
any changes to this
it remains the exact same now
one thing to notice is reversing the
groups
is pretty easy but we need to do a
little more than just
that right see one's next pointer is
initially at two
but at the end it's pointing at four
so really we have to make this jump
so that's where the difficulty comes
from and that's what i'm going to
explain once we've reversed these groups
then we actually have to put them
together
so like most linked list problems i'm
just going to tell you from the start
this time that we
are going to need a dummy node because
we're potentially
modifying the head of the list right
like
first this is the head but at the end
this is going to be the head i don't
want to deal with edge cases and stuff
so just having a dummy node here helps
us a lot
so we have k equals two
i wanna reverse the first group how do i
do that
let's say we start here all i have to do
is
count by k so one
two so this is the k-th
node so now starting from here
we're gonna start reversing so the next
pointer
of one is gonna be reversed but
this is the dummy node so i don't really
care about it
so i'm actually gonna set this equal
let's say to null for now
next i'm gonna move to the next node
which happens to be our kth
node i'm going to say its next pointer
is also going to be reversed now it's
set
to 1 right the previous node
now we move to the next node but we
know we just passed our kth node so
we're not reversing this yet we're going
to reverse it
with its own group right now we're only
reversing
this group so we're finished so now if
you look at what we just did we
took this portion reversed that group
right now we have this
and we didn't really touch this so it
stayed the same
but look what we just did we cut our
linked list
in half it's not even connected anymore
we reversed the first group which is
what we wanted
but we didn't want to split them so
instead of setting
this one to null we can set it
to what the last what our cond where our
condition would
stop right this is where our condition
is going to stop so the node
right after k is where we're going to
set
the next pointer of this
also we don't want to forget that our
our dummy node over here should point at
the
first node so great we've done
the first group now we want to move to
the next group
so don't forget k equals 2 so
this is our first node this is our
second node
so this happens to be the kth node so
again
we're going to take this pointer and
reverse it
and in the first example i showed you
that it's going to be set
to null but really we know
it's going to be set to k dot
next right k dot next we know that this
is
k so k dot next is over here
so after i cross out the next pointer
i'm going to move it
over here next we want to reverse
the link of 4 so we can remove this
pointer and
reverse it we know that this is the
previous
node and the last thing remember don't
forget
before we took our dummy pointer and
then set it
to two instead of one but
right now we're gonna take one's next
pointer
and instead set it to four
rather than three because we're
reversing
this group so one dot next is gonna be
at four so these pointers can get
complicated and can definitely get
messy even when you're looking at a
picture so let's redraw it
so this is what our linked list looks
like
now we still have our dummy node over
here we reversed the first group
we reversed the second group let's look
at the third group
so we're starting here this is one let's
get the kth node okay we want the second
node we try here
this is null right so the kth node
doesn't even exist
so this group is too small so we're
finished
we don't have to do anything anymore and
so notice we got
two one four three five
when you go back here that's exactly
what we have in the output
two one four three and five
so now let's actually look at the code
we want a
dummy node to be initialized
at the beginning so we're gonna give it
a default value
zero and the next pointer is gonna be
set to our head
of the linked list i'm also gonna have
a pointer i'm gonna call the group
previous
which i'm gonna initially set to dummy
but the reason we have this
is if we have a group so if our group
was 2 and 3 and we want to reverse it
the output would look like this right so
we took this group and reversed it to do
that we need to have a pointer of one
node
right before the start of our group so
we can then say
one dot next is three so we're always
going to save
one node right before our group now
we're just gonna start
looping i'm just gonna say while true
because i'm lazy
so we're going to need to get the kth
node so we know
how long or how big our group is how
like what exactly the group is we're
trying to reverse so i'm going to write
a helper function to do that
just called get k and we're just going
to pass
in two parameters the current node and
the what the value k
is so starting at cur we're gonna
increment
we're gonna uh we're gonna shift k times
and then return that
kth node so while cur is not at the end
and
k is greater than zero we're gonna
update current
and decrement k then at the end we can
return
the kth node that we want to so now i'm
gonna call that helper function
get k and what's the start that we're
going to pass in we're going to pass in
the group
previous because the group previous is
not a part of our group
and let's store this in case but
what if the kth node doesn't even exist
what does that
mean that means we've gotten to the last
group
in our linked list and it's not big
enough
for us to reverse it so we can stop then
so we can say
if not k if it's null then terminate so
break out of the loop so that's why we
have a true here
and that's going to be the condition
that breaks us out so
similar to how we have we always keep
track of one node before the start of
our group
let's keep track of a node right after
our group so if this is the kth
node let's just get kth dot
next and store that in group dot next
so one node right after our group so now
we can start
actually reversing right reversing
the group and we can use two pointers to
do that if you've solved
the delete code easy problem reversal
linked list you probably know how to do
this
i'm going to set previous to null and
current
group previous dot next
because this is the first node in our
group but there's just one problem with
this remember
if we have previous initially set to
null
we're gonna end up splitting our linked
lists and we don't want to have multiple
linked lists so
instead of this being null in reality
it's going to be kth dot next
so the rest of this is basically just
reverse a linked list so
while current does not reach the end in
this case the
end is the end is group dot next and now
we're just reversing so i'm going to put
it in a temporary variable
current.next we're going to update
current.next
set it to previous previous is going to
be set to
current and then current is going to be
shifted by 1 which is
stored in our temporary variable so
remember how
kth was the last node in our group now
we want it to be the first node in our
group
and what we can do is say group
previous so one node before the start of
our group
dot next is now going to be
kth so what we're doing is putting kth
at the beginning of this group
but we also want to update group
previous for the next iteration of our
loop right when we come back around
we want this node to be where it should
be we want this pointer to be where it
should be
and to do that what we can do is
actually have a and i have another
temporary variable so
in that we're going to store group
previous
dot next before we end up updating it
and what this current what this
initially stores
is the first node in our group remember
kth was the last node in our group this
is the first node in our group
and so we want to set this equal to that
because this started as the first node
in our group
but now it's going to be the last node
and that's
what we want this to be set to so i
think probably this is the most
complicated part of the problem and
pointers in general are really
kind of annoying even drawing a picture
is kind of annoying because you have to
cross out a bunch of pointers
but right now all we need to do is
return
the new head of the linked list which is
going to be
dummy.next so this is the final code so
it does work
pretty well if this was helpful please
like and subscribe it supports the
channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon